[Música]
a
escala en parís braulio more
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español donde damos la palabra a
artistas políticos gente de las ciencias
de las artes los deportes nos
encontramos aquí en el corazón mismo de
parís ustedes lo habrán visto escala en
parís ha salido de sus estudios para
colocarse en uno de los lugares más
emblemáticos de la capital francesa
estamos en el palacio de salou donde se
concentra la ciudad de la arquitectura y
el patrimonio es aquí donde a partir de
este mes de abril hasta finales de este
año tendrá lugar la exposición sin duda
alguna más importante de francia en este
2022 hacemos referencia a la exposición
machu picchu y los tesoros del perú para
hablarnos de ello saludamos la presencia
en esta escala en parís en este palacio
de chayo de la conquista pachas que es
ni más ni menos que es ministra de la
cultura de perú es arqueóloga y que
además es la curadora de esta magnífica
gran exposición o la bienvenida a esta
escala agraria
su tiempo hablar de la cultura inca de
la civilización es hablar ni más ni
menos que de la civilización más
importante del conosur antes de la
llegada de colom antes de la conquista y
la destrucción de los españoles pero yo
quisiera preguntarle cuánto tiempo se
han tardado en concebir esta magnífica
disposición y sobre todo de dónde viene
esta idea bueno en realidad hace muchos
años ya la empresa que ha organizado
esta exposición tenía una idea de hacer
una gran exposición donde se pudiera
presentar la civilización andina no a un
gran público y bueno se concretaron los
planes hace más o menos un par de años
con esta alianza con el museo larco del
cual soy directora también siendo
curadora de la exposición co curadora
con una colega arqueóloga también
francesa carole cerezo y se planteó
hacer una exposición que pudiera
itinerar en diversas ciudades del mundo
pero precisamente
considerando una muy grande colección e
importante colección del museo larco
junto con algunas piezas de machu donde
se pudiese llegar a entender por qué los
incas machu picchu terminan siendo un
símbolo tan importante no solamente para
la peruanidad sino para las
civilizaciones
efectivamente de el hemisferio sur como
gran civilización del hemisferio sur
entonces se concreta este plan hemos
venido trabajando desde el año
2020 para la apertura primero en la
ciudad de boca ratón y bueno esta gran
sede tan céntrica y tan importante para
nosotros que es acá en la ciudad de
parís una usted lo decía precisamente es
una exposición itinerante es un
pasaporte abierto de la cultura peruana
lo decía el año pasado se presentó en
boca ratón en florida eeuu este año va a
estar aquí entiendo que después va a
viajar a italia muy probablemente
australia japón es una manera de
presentar de itinerar como pasaporte
este gran saber esta gran civilización
inca y del pueblo peruano
exactamente porque la idea es llegar a
un público cada vez más amplio que a
través de una exposición como ésta
es una exposición nueva novedosa en la
presentación de grandes colecciones
importantes colecciones precolombinas de
diversas culturas originarias del
antiguo perú junto con elementos
inmersivos junto con elementos
audiovisuales que han sido muy bien
concebidos también hay una experiencia
extraordinaria de realidad aumentada de
un viaje en una perspectiva que uno
nunca va a poder hacer en machu picchu
que sobrevolar lo no todo esto permite
una presentación que esperamos llegue a
un público que quiera tener la
experiencia general de acercarse a la
sociedad andina en general con algunos
conceptos de su cosmovisión ver grandes
tesoros piezas emblemáticas que
realmente son de una factura
primorosa muy sofisticada
más qué
pueda divertirse y entender porque hay
una narrativa hay un cuento que contamos
para colocar a la sociedad precolombina
peruana en el sitial que tiene que estar
que es a la par de las grandes
civilizaciones del mundo y como gran
civilización de ustedes hacen el favor
de presentar 190 piezas cual más
excepcional una que otra y que muchas de
ellas salen por primera vez de perú si
efectivamente hay una hay una
combinación digamos de objetos
como decirlos como obras maestras
digamos de la colección del museo que
representan las diversas culturas pero
no solamente son objetos como estos que
vemos acá de metal de plata de oro que
son muy representativos de nuestras
culturas precolombinas hay una linda
colección de alfarería de cerámica que
en realidad era la manera como los
antiguos peruanos modelaban el mundo lo
explicaban representando rituales
ceremonias mitos también hay artefactos
de piedra como ídolos o monolitos que
tuvieron una posición central en el
culto de las civilizaciones bastante
antiguas también otros artefactos de
madera y de otros materiales entonces se
va a ver realmente una
exposición donde se puede dar una cuenta
de la gran maestría en el trabajo de los
diferentes materiales de nuestros
ancestros de los artistas no de nuestras
sociedades antiguas hola yo quisiera
preguntarle a aquellas personas que
tengan la oportunidad la posibilidad de
venir a ver esta significa exposición
podrán eventualmente descubrir algunas
de las casi 11.000 piezas que en su
momento devolvió la universidad de yale
de eeuu a perú que recordemos mantuvo
casi de manera forzada durante casi un
siglo y que fue gracias al esfuerzo del
gobierno peruano que pudieron
restituirse estas piezas no son
exactamente del museo
concha de la casa concha que es donde
están estos artefactos ahora en perú
pero si hay objetos de machu picchu o
sea que estamos hablando del mismo tipo
de objetos que encontrándose en la
ciudadela nos permiten ver que se
llevaron a cabo diversas actividades de
consumo de alimentos de brindis rituales
en la ciudadela de machu picchu entonces
son el mismo tipo de objetos no pero que
nos dan una idea efectivamente de
esta ciudadela y de su función y además
de alguna manera porque fue la síntesis
de un desarrollo milenario no cierto
porque tenemos toda la idea de machu
picchu pero en realidad machu picchu
estamos hablando de más de tres mil años
exactos estamos hablando de una
construcción que se hizo en el siglo 15
muy probablemente pero tenemos
4500 y 5000 años de desarrollo de alta
civilización antes del imperio de los
incas entonces lo que esta exposición
explica es un poco cómo llegamos a ese
punto magnífico de desarrollo y como
gran civilización como gran confluencia
de civilizaciones finalmente de culturas
ellos desarrollan entre otras cosas la
civilización inca la escritura de una
manera diferente a la que conocemos con
otras grandes civilizaciones hay una
cosa que llama mi atención háblenos de
los que están presentes en este
exposición me encanta la pregunta porque
tú lo ha dicho grau leo tiene mucho que
ver con ideas que desde muy pequeños
muchos de los sudamericanos y peruanos
hemos creció diciendo aquí no había
escritura no y en realidad es una manera
de entender la escritura desde una
visión eurocéntrica no que en la que se
descartan o no se consideran otro tipo
de registro de información que
efectivamente en nuestras sociedades se
llevó a cabo un registro información
tridimensional en el caso por ejemplo de
la cerámica como lo mencionado y en él
los quipus que fueron un sistema de
cuerdas anudadas en donde los diferentes
nudos en las diferentes posiciones de
las cuerdas cuerdas que además eran
torcidas con hilos de diferentes colores
guardando información cualitativamente
diferente como si fueran files de una
computadora no es cierto y se puede
registrar numéricamente información de
manera digital es decir la presencia o
ausencia del nudo en una posición
respectiva más arriba al medio o más
abajo de la cuerda principal y va
registrando información no sólo no es un
ábaco no es un sistema de conteo es un
sistema de registro digital de
información con la cual se podría llevar
digamos el registro de cantidades de con
de producción de población pero también
información cualitativa de jerarquías un
cierto de genealogías y si bien no se ha
llegado al desciframiento completo de
los quipus ya hoy en día los avances de
la investigación de muchos profesionales
indican que estamos frente a un sistema
de registro información muy avanzado
comparativamente podríamos poder
considerarlo como un data veis no hay
otra cosa que llama ni atención a los
incas en su momento también se
diferencian por ejemplo de los egipcios
en el tratamiento de sus muertos
háblenos de esto precisamente no
utilizan la momificación como se conoce
en egipto pero se aproximan mucho
utilizando los medios naturales el aire
la altura de los andes' más de 3600
metros exactamente porque si hablamos de
momias porque hay una suerte de
momificación natural no es cierto tanto
en la costa por ejemplo en espacios muy
áridos se han encontrado cuerpos que
parecieran haber sido
digamos preservados con quitándole de
repente en la parte interna y no es así
han sido preservados por la aridez del
suelo por la profundidad de los
entierros que eran en verdad muy
cuidados por sus comunidades porque no
solamente los muertos estaban muertos en
el concepto que nosotros tenemos hoy en
día en la modernidad eran en realidad
ancestros que aún tenían importancia
para sus comunidades y que eran
revisitados revestidos se les llevaban
nuevamente ofrendas se les alimentaba
porque eran ellos los responsables de
que la vida se regenerará en este mundo
que se concibe el mundo de abajo como un
mundo de regeneración y en las alturas
como tú bien lo has mencionado también
otras prácticas de llevar a algunas
ofrendas humanas que lo hubo en las
alturas de las montañas con el
congelamiento porque era la mejor
ofrenda que se podía hacer a estos picos
de las montañas de los cuales
bajaba pues el líquido vital que ha sido
central en la cosmovisión andina en
general una conquista una cuestión que
llama mi atención de estamos aquí en una
sala de las que más piezas
espectaculares presentan son piezas en
oro extraordinarias todas ellas una cual
más que las otras pero si me pudiera
permitir cuál es la pieza que más le
gusta a usted ahí yo tengo mis
preferencias
y
si en realidad tengo la preferencia por
una sección de la exhibición porque es
una sección en donde presentamos a un
personaje legendario un héroe mitológico
que fue bautizado por el fundador del
museo larco como ai apaec es un nombre
en música en lengua muchik pero porque
le tengo una preferencia especial porque
nos ha permitido contar la historia de
un personaje heroico como existen en
todas las grandes civilizaciones como
william es como orfeo como hércules y yo
siento y creo y lo he visto también en
la exhibición previa como es es una ruta
esta parte de la exhibición en la que el
público se siente muy involucrado porque
entiende la narrativa que es propia de
la sociedad andina mochica en particular
pero que es muy universal entonces yo
tengo mucho gusto por esa sección porque
es un cuento que contamos y se
complementa perfectamente con toda la
ritualidad que se presenta en las demás
galerías con esta asombrosa presentación
de los atuendos de los ancestros de los
grandes señores y señoras del antiguo
perú pero sobre todo nos permite dar el
toque digamos de las grandes mitologías
que han permitido que el mundo pues
siempre se imaginé estos momentos de
construcción de civilización alentados
por un personaje civilizador heroico no
estamos llegando ya al final de esta
escala en parís no me queda sino
agradecerle a la conquista pachas
exministra de la cultura curadora de
esta magnífica exposición en habernos
acompañado muy amable gracias a la
célula vídeo de radio france
internacional a florencia valdez nuestra
productora ya ustedes les damos una
nueva cita aquí la próxima semana en
otra escala en parís
[Música]